we're back at the shopping center where
on monday two russian cruise missiles
hit one in the shopping mall one just
behind it 18 people were killed dozens
more were injured and since then they've
been cleaning up since then they've
continued to find body parts here this
is one of the most high profile attacks
on civilian targets of this war
a war that has seen volunteers come to
fight from various countries including
canada on thursday global news met
matthew mcgill from calgary a month
after the invasion mcgill quit his job
as a truck driver to come support the
ukrainian effort mcgill is a signals
expert he served with the canadian
military back in the 90s and said he was
motivated to help ukraine because of
what russia was doing to civilians the
russians were killing civilians and
invading a sovereign country who never
bothered them at all was in fact their
ally for years and
i felt that i needed to do
whatever i could do
to help with the fight
it's very canadian to work for the peace
of the world
it's very canadian to sacrifice your
life in order to defend a foreign
country against aggression it's very
canadian to
not think of your own welfare but to
think of the broader welfare i asked
mcgill about his message for canadians
on canada day
be
grateful
that we don't have war in canada
because it's
it's crap here
it's it's no fun
and everybody suffers so just be very
thankful that in canada we we have peace
and
we're not under threat
mcgill says he will return to calgary
and his trucking job at the end of
august until then he and other
volunteers other volunteers from canada
will be here fighting for ukraine
bearing in mind the losses that this
country has suffered including the
people who died at this shopping center
shawn o'shea global news kremenchuk
ukraine